the government is publishing its
long-awaited plans for a revamped
immigration system to begin at the start
of next year ministers say the
points-based system will shift the
emphasis from low-skilled to
high-skilled workers our political
correspondent Kate McCann is in
Westminster people will be watching this
very closely Kate more details to come
later this evening but what do we know
so far that's right well we're starting
to hear some of the details about what
the new immigration system is going to
look like and really this was always
going to be one of the biggest
challenges for whichever government took
control of brexit because immigration
was such a huge part of that initial
vote to leave the European Union that
Boris Johnson has always been
consistently clear that he wants a
system which is fair for all citizens
from all around the world and that is
what the government is proposing with
its new points-based system workers
would have to earn a certain salary
amount around 25,000 pounds although
there would be exceptions you could earn
20,000 if you were from a particular
profession with the right skills
there will be no low skilled immigration
routes and the government believes that
would exempt around 70% of European
Union citizens from coming to the UK now
clearly their intention here is to take
back control of the immigration system
that's what the Home Secretary herself
has consistently said they also want to
make sure that the UK is getting workers
into the right areas so there are
specific requirements for language for
some of the professions for some of the
qualifications that people will need to
have and they will build up a system of
points which will allow them to move in
to work in the UK now there will be some
exemptions for people like artists
religious leaders there will be some
specific youth schemes and things for
students to encourage exchanges from
countries around the world but there has
been some criticism of these plans there
are some who would have liked to have
seen regional salary differences for
example workers in the north of the
country perhaps paid a little bit less
and some of those in the south that's
not going to happen and they've also
been some concerns from sectors like
Social Care and particularly agriculture
because they believe that some kind of
system like this would mean they
wouldn't be able to have enough workers
the government's message is clear though
they say that the low-skilled
immigration will end
and the UK economy will need to
rebalance itself and start looking to
upskilling British workers to get them
to do some of the jobs that perhaps have
been taken by European Union workers in
the past this will be one of the biggest
challenges for Boris Johnson's
government so tomorrow will be a big day
when we finally see that full system
unveiled
you